i'm dana perrino i'm juan williams i'm
kennedy and this is the fox news rundown
wednesday may 11 2022
i'm dave anthony the prices at the pump
are higher than ever and we may have to
get used to it memorial day weekend
we're going to be breaking more records
um and depending on how things go after
that you know we should level off at
that point but you know we're not going
to go down that much we're in a new era
of higher gasoline prices
i'm lisa brady the issue that's firing
up activists around the country might
not be a sure thing at the polls in
november so it's not just as simple as
saying you know do you support right to
life for you know women's choice it is
much more complicated and i'm tammy
bruce i've got the final word on the fox
news rundown
[Music]
i have a question for you so why do gas
prices keep going up so high they've hit
record highs again this week
aaa has regular around 440 per gallon
but president biden says oil prices have
been steady lately unlike in march when
gas first spiked to a record which he
blames on mr putin's war in ukraine
russian oil is now banned here and the
president insists here at home u.s oil
and gas production is approaching record
levels so he blames oil companies making
record profits and republicans for not
embracing the need for clean energy so
in the future american families are no
longer subject to the winds and of
dictators halfway around the world but
gop senator josh hawley tells fox he's
responsible for this inflationary binge
he's the one who's given it to us gas
prices have been going up for an entire
year and a half now under him diesel
also at a record high price well over
550 a gallon it's even worse for mike
kocharski with jkc trucking in illinois
they haul produce which needs to be
refrigerated the cooling unit runs on
diesel also on top of the trucks our
costs are even further more than other
truckers he says their fuel costs are up
47 percent from a year ago yardani
research estimates the average american
family will pay 2 000
more this year for gasoline this was an
accident that's been waiting to happen
right phil flynn is a senior market
analyst with a price futures group and a
fox business network contributor the
biden administration they want to call
it the putin price hike well you know
we've been predicting that joe biden's
energy policies was going to create
record high prices when he got elected
so i call it the biden price hike putin
may have helped things along but it was
really joe biden that set the stage for
these record high gasoline prices yeah i
know and republicans have been saying
that as well blaming his energy policies
and all that with especially i think the
biggest thing was right away when he
shut down the keystone xl pipeline from
continuing and being built
if that didn't happen if we were in a
world in which the keystone xl pipeline
was going to continue where would that
be about now well we'd be getting oil
from canada right now that we can't get
through pipeline so we it would already
be on the market you know the argument a
few months ago well that pipeline
wouldn't have even been built well it
would have been built by now but if you
add to the keystone pipeline you had the
drilling moratorium you had the
discouragement of investment in fossil
fuels new regulations new royalty taxes
everything that would just say to all
investors hey
in america stay away from fossil fuel
investment because the government hasn't
has a has a target on your back they're
going to tax you they're going to
regulate you they're going to accuse you
of price gouging
they're coming after you so stay away
all right now the president has said
look
there are idled oil wells on federal
land and they're considering putting
fees on the producers that aren't using
them and they also want to put fees on
uh acres of federal land that say oil
companies might own that are not
producing that they're not doing
anything with that land that's what the
white house keeps saying
what's the story with that the story is
they're already paying fees for that
land so they're going to raise it more
and discourage production there's a lot
of reasons why
the drillers are not drying on a parcel
of land one of the easiest things is
sometimes they buy them in bulk and they
don't even know if there's oil on that
land right so they have to do studies
and stuff and you know or they're
drilling on one part of the property but
not the other parcel of property because
some has oil and gas and the other thing
is is that even if they wanted to
drill
then the dividend administration's
permitting process is so slow that it
takes years you know to get something
going
listen there's no doubt about it on some
of these federal lands that they they
want to lease out that there is oil
there that they could bring on a lot
quicker than these leases that are
already so called not be used but what
really this is just another tired
talking point by the democratic party
that they throw out every time
they they're concerned about oil prices
to deflect blame from their policies now
one thing president biden has been doing
tapping into the u.s strategic petroleum
reserve a million barrels a day for six
months he started that late march hoping
to ease gas prices like he also tried to
do back in november and in february but
again we're at new record levels it
hasn't worked and it's because it was
the wrong prescription for the wrong
disease okay
the war in the ukraine really didn't cut
off oil supply to the u.s or to the
world uh in fact they're still importing
russian oil in europe uh so there wasn't
a shortage of oil the the history of
biden with the strategic reserve he
started to release oil from the reserve
in november well before we were even
concerned about russia invading ukraine
you know he said at that time it was
gasoline prices were up and he tried to
manipulate prices to send a message to
opec because they wouldn't listen to him
now he's releasing it because of the war
of ukraine the thing is is that the
strategic petroleum reserve was never
built for that okay it's not big enough
to to do that back when it was filled to
its capacity in december of 2009 uh the
strategic reserve held
727 million barrels of oil
now
at its capacity the world basically in
rough numbers when it's hidden on all
cylinders consumes more than that on a
daily basis so the whole world could
wipe out the entire reserve you know in
in in a day right that's crazy and yeah
it is crazy you know i mean it's a
percentage of the world supply so um
actually i should say in a week i should
say a week because okay 100 million
barrels a day okay okay still crazy okay
so that so crazy right exactly
so let me ask you this because we you
and i have spoken about this before
people want the us to be energy
independent they don't want any anybody
else's oil coming in but that's really
not the way the oil market works right
we
refine
not necessarily the oil we produce here
right i mean we we need
we need the foreign oil market they need
us it's a it we don't work on our own
here you're right i mean you know when
you look at the global oil market it
really is uh like a global super highway
right
where
oil products depending on their quality
and for in the demand for these products
uh move from one part of the world to
the other right and so when we talk
about energy independence we really look
at net exports
for the united states our refineries
were really built
based on imported oil then we had the
shell revolution miracle
and we found a way to get oil out of
shale and the quality of that oil though
is much different than the oil we were
used to refining
so
that type of oil really is better
refined in other places like europe
where their refineries were built for a
lighter blend of oil
so
we're in a much better case where we
would normally
export you know u.s shall oil and import
heavier oil
you know you have this symbiotic
relationship in the global oil market
but if you stack back at the end of the
day when you control a bigger percentage
of global production you have a bigger
say in the global oil price and
the the real reason why we had low
inflation you know the last couple of
years was because u.s energy producers
were so good at producing a lot of oil
we're good at exporting a lot of oil
we're good at exporting a lot of product
and we did that
and it kept opec in check
and it helped grow our economy
all right now gas prices as we know are
at this new record level
we're getting into the summer
usually that means
the gas that is refined now the gasoline
used in the summer is a different
formula right and then we always hear
it's more expensive is that still the
case it is now the biden administration
did issue some waivers on the amount of
ethanol you can put into the gasoline
you know for the summer
and um by doing so they provided a
little bit of cushion because on a hot
summer day anybody who's filled up their
gasoline tank you know you see those
fumes coming out oh yeah gas tank oh
yeah well that's evaporation rate right
and they formulate that so in the summer
when it's hot it doesn't evaporate as
much and it doesn't add as much
pollution because that coming out of
your gas tank is pollution coming out of
the tank uh so those reformulated blends
come into play but they're they're a lot
more complicated to make you have to
have specific refineries that do it and
so you generally have those prices go up
on top of that more people drive in the
summer than they do in the winter you
know people go on vacation people are
you know they're not afraid to be you
know getting iced out on the roads and
things so it definitely you know you see
the demand go up so
prices are probably going to go higher
from here
they are i mean memorial day weekend
we're going to be breaking more records
um and depending on how things go after
that you know we should level off at
that point but
you know we're not going to go down that
much we're in a new era of higher
gasoline prices and this is definitely
going to keep the market on edge for
sure so let me ask you about diesel
because it's also so it's had a much
bigger surge
year-over-year than regular gas
why is that a couple of reasons um we've
had a ban on venezuelan oil that we
traditionally used our refineries used
to create a lot of diesel
they tried to replace that with russia
you know gas oil which produces diesel
but because of the ban so that's created
a shortage but it's not just a shortage
here in the united states it's really a
global shortage and so we're getting
caught up in this diesel shortage around
the globe and that is a problem because
all the shipping companies that have
already had supply chain issues they're
paying diesel diesel is a very important
fuel
in the economy is it not it really is it
means that the cost of everything goes
up you know and you know the way things
are looking right now it seems like
it's going to be the energy the push is
you know pushes us into a recession
because there's no quick fixes for all
the problems that we should have seen
coming months ago right or years ago uh
and and and so you know the sad part
about it is prices are probably just
going to go up and so companies say hey
that's enough we can't afford it and
then prices then come back down so you
said this is a new era are we talking
about four dollar gas and five dollar
diesel for for a while
years
i think for years unless we get into a
big recession i mean the one thing that
can bring down prices faster than you
know
i'm drilling for oil is a slow down in
economic growth
and that's a big concern if the federal
reserve on the other hand is able to
engineer a soft landing that soft
landing is going to have to include
you know gasoline prices that are going
to be close to four and five dollars a
gallon and diesel prices are you know
they're gonna be near four or five
dollars a gallon as well
phil flynn
senior market analyst at the price
futures group fox business network
contributor good to talk to you again
phil thanks so much
thank you i appreciate it
[Music]
this is tammy bruce with your fox news
commentary coming up
the abortion debate stirred up by a leak
at the u.s supreme court has quickly
become a new round of finger-pointing
over the tactics used by some protesters
these thugs
have no business at the private homes
of any government officials these
supreme court justices or anyone else
texas republican senator ted cruz
accuses president biden and the
democratic party of turning a blind eye
but white house spokeswoman jensaki
accuses some conservatives being
hypocrites for calling out these
protests while remaining silent for
years on protests that have happened
outside of the homes of school board
members the michigan secretary of state
she also says the president believes
violence threats and intimidation have
no place in political discourse there's
been a steady drumbeat of midterm
elections messaging tied to abortion
ever since the leak the democratic party
president biden himself and the house
speaker all warning that other rights
are at stake if roe vs wade falls but
could the full court press to capitalize
on the issue backfire for democrats i
don't know if it's going to backfire i'm
just not sure it's the silver bullet the
democrats or at least some democrats
think it is in terms of flipping the
script on this year's midterms tom bevin
is the co-founder and president of real
clear politics you know there was this
thinking within the democratic party
that this is one of those issues
unlike the other issues that they've
faced whether it's immigration or
student loan debt or or some of these
other issues where the issue either
pleased the base of the party but
alienated swing voters
or police swing voters and alienated the
base of the party this was an issue that
they thought would motivate both
um and it's a very complex issue and
it's also one that you know is competing
for
primacy with with other potent issues
and you know someone who's a single
issue voter on abortion is is already
spoken for i mean if whether they're a
democrat or republican so the question
is how many minds is this going to
change
and how salient is it going to be
if voters are still in november facing
six dollar gallon gas and eight percent
inflation so we'll have to wait and see
how this plays out but
i think the protests might backfire a
little bit in terms of the
aggressiveness with which
some
more
progressive elements of the democratic
party and more even militant elements of
the democratic party have been outside
supreme court justice's homes and
obviously the bombing of the
right to life organization in wisconsin
i mean those are the kind of things that
will
alienate voters and turn them off from
this issue because they don't want to
see that yeah has the white house taken
a strong enough
stand against that violence
you know shinsaki released a tweet and
then said from the podium that you know
the president obviously in the white
house they don't condone violence and
you know want only peaceful protesting
but
you know she was asked about this last
week
and didn't say anything she said there's
a lot of passion among people
on this issue i really thought it was a
statement that should have been made
five six days earlier
and so you know by the time they got
around to saying it you know the signal
had already been sent
the white house keeps pointing to polls
showing that a majority of americans
favor
a woman's right to choose but what about
the broader argument they're also trying
to make that other rights could be in
jeopardy
you know is that a winning argument
you know i don't think so i mean look
the abortion fight is one that's been
going on in this country for 50 years
you know the right to life movement is a
huge movement
that you know has been
fully developed and very passionate
there just isn't an equivalent push
anywhere in the country among anyone to
do any of the things that democrats are
accusing
you know republicans of outlawing gay
marriage or interracial marriage i mean
these things like nobody's in favor of
that there is no movement for that and
so
right under the broader under the
broader umbrella of sort of personal
privacy is what the president keeps
going back to
yes and this idea
our mayor lori lightfoot tweeted out you
know this is a call to arms against the
supreme court to all of her lgbtq plus
colleagues that it's it's time to stand
up i mean
i don't think that's gonna sell with the
american people because i think that's
just too dramatic too overwrought and i
think the public is smart enough to see
through that
for many people abortion does tend to be
a more nuanced issue there was a fox
news poll that found 63 percent want the
supreme court to let roe versus wade
stand but 54 also said they would
support their state banning abortion
after 15 weeks
so for the white house for democrats it
seems you know not always as simple as
saying the people are with us
on this issue
that's right as i said earlier you just
point out it is a complicated issue i
mean in general there's a broad support
for
women's choice on the issue but
the question is do you support abortions
all the way up to the moment of birth
massive majorities are against that so
it's not just as simple as saying you
know do you support right to life for
you know women's choice it is much more
complicated and nuanced and the other
thing too is you know the public is not
and it's not really the public's fault
it's it's the fault of the media for not
communicating properly and the spin that
goes into it but
overturning roe v wade is not outlawing
abortion all across the country it'll be
left up to the states to decide and so
you will have some states will outlaw it
i'm sure some there are some deep red
states that will push for an outright
ban on abortion and obviously in deep
blue states you will have abortion as
very non-restrictive abortion policies
in places like illinois and california
new york etc
and in some of the more uh you know
purplish states i'm sure you'll have
some policies that end up somewhere in
between so the idea that somehow when
this happens the day that this ruling
officially comes out that we are back to
the 1800s and it's the handmaidens tale
i mean
you know they're creating expectations
that will not be met
and that's going to be a political
problem for them as well
this all fueling
debate in congress about what could be
done nationally
the senate democrats working on
trying to
make
abortion rights part of federal law the
senate republican leader mitch mcconnell
has suggested
there could be an effort to have a
national
abortion ban
um and each side pretty much accuses the
other of extreme
views on this issue right so it's
it's kind of like does that mean that
each side also risks going too far or
miscalculating what the public wants
sure i mean this is one of those issues
where you know you have people on either
side that are very very passionate about
it and they have also staked out the
most extreme positions and they are the
loudest in the debate but the vast
majority of the public is somewhere in
the the huge middle they may support you
know women's choice but only up until a
certain period of time they may call
themselves pro-life but allow for you
know exceptions for rape and incest so
there's a whole
spectrum of opinion and positions on
this
that americans have that are not
represented by the debate that takes
place in washington and in the media
and as a consequence you have as you
pointed out democrats moving forward to
try and codify roe v wade knowing that
they don't have the enough votes to do
it and you have mitch mcconnell sort of
inexplicably
putting his foot in it and suggesting
that somehow republicans are going to
push a national abortion ban i don't
think that's the case i don't think they
would have the votes for it either quite
frankly so even in the senate that they
controlled after november
um so
as a result
to your point
the discussion does not mirror where the
public is
the vast majority of the public is on
this issue on tuesday senate minority
leader mcconnell batted down talk of
pursuing a national abortion ban telling
reporters i think the sentiment in my
conference
is for this issue to be dealt with at
the state level while senate majority
leader chuck schumer doubled down on
criticism of the supreme court's
conservative majority this is a giant
step backwards
in the rights of women and the rights of
americans he says if enacted the
decision would live in infamy a new poll
from yahoo news and yougov finds
confidence in the court dropping from 70
percent with some or a lot of confidence
in the court down to 51
over the past 20 months as a
conservative majority was formed is that
dangerous for the supreme court or for
either party well it's dangerous for the
country because the supreme court is one
of the institutions
that you know needs to have the trust
and respect of of the public given their
role in our
you know democracy in our constitutional
republic so and this is something you
know gallup has tracked these numbers as
well and it's something that's been
not just the supreme court quite frankly
across a whole host of institutions
whether it's congress the presidency
news media
business
uh the supreme court has suffered about
a 10 12 point drop in the last 20 years
it seems to have accelerated
in part because of the way that that
the court has well the the
nomination process has taken place right
you know democrats are furious that
mitch mcconnell wouldn't give merrick
garland a hearing republicans are
furious at the way that the you know
nominees have been treated particularly
brett kavanaugh
then you've got you know this leak this
violation unprecedented violation of the
trust and norms of the supreme court
only
exacerbates the idea that uh
people are losing trust in the
institution and that's a problem for our
for our democracy but it's it's hard to
see how
how that perception has changed because
it's just again across the board we've
seen
all of our institutions are viewed as
being politicized whether it's the
intelligence services
you know all these institutions that are
supposed to be sort of above and beyond
the daily grind of our partisan politics
have been absorbed into them and and as
a result
you know they're they're in danger
there's an axios piece that suggests
republicans
aren't feeling as confident about the
midterms after this
supreme court leak um possibly because
of you know what could be a disconnect
between
the way the base reacts to the issue and
the way swing voters um might feel about
it uh
it's does it again really all come down
to
what's happening in november how bad are
gas prices then how bad is inflation in
general then um because that's still the
number one issue that people talk about
in the polls right
it is uh by a huge margin i mean two
three times depending on which poll
you're looking at inflation is is the
number one issue and in the poll the
quinnipiac poll came out just before the
leak of the supreme court
abortion was ranked tied for ninth out
of 13 issues that were offered to voters
as their main concern
inflation was number one at 31
immigration was number two at 10 or 11
percent and so abortion was way down the
list now it's obviously going to be much
much higher in the next round of polling
but the question is how high does it
rise how long does it stay there
there doesn't seem to be any indication
that it's going to
drop in any significant way before the
election and and the other problem for
democrats is that
a lot of the perceptions about the
election
are formed right now it's not going to
matter um if if the last reading we get
before the election on inflation is a
drop of one percent or something that
will be heralded as good news but it you
know isn't going to change the outcome
because people's perceptions are already
locked in and and so for that reason i
think
again the abortion issue might play uh
you know on the margins but it is not it
is not going to
be the silver bullet that flips the
script tom bevin co-founder and
president of real clear politics thanks
so much for your time absolutely so
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network stay
on top of the latest news and
information from fox news listen and
download the fox news hourly update on
your time the trending stories you need
anytime you want it listen and download
now by going to foxnewspodcasts.com
rate and review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
it's time for your fox news commentary
what's on your mind it is now revealed
that the biden administration which has
brought us an orwellian disinformation
board that they insist will not be used
against american citizens was purchasing
cell phone location data and movement
information to surveil american citizens
during the covid crisis
how many times did we hear that anyone
concerned about digital vaccine
passports and lockdowns being used as an
excuse to surveil our private lives and
movement was a nutty conspiracy theorist
lo and behold it seems like that is
exactly what is happening ostensibly to
track compliance with lockdowns in this
case the cdc tracked people wherever
they went
including schools church and even when
visiting neighbors
using cell phone tracking data the
investigative website vice broke the
news reporting quote the centers for
disease control and prevention bought
access to location data harvested from
tens of millions of phones in the united
states to perform analysis of compliance
with curfews track patterns of people
visiting k-12 schools and specifically
to monitor the effectiveness of policy
in the navajo nation
the documents also show that although
the cdc used covet 19 as a reason to buy
access to the data more quickly it
intended to use it for more general cdc
purposes
so where do we start the issue here is
that a government bureaucracy believes
surveilling the american people on mass
was a perfectly fine thing to do you
know in the name of safety
we know the democrats never want to let
a good crisis go to waste for them every
crisis presents an opportunity to do the
worst thing possible in this case it was
sweeping away the rule of law and
constitutional order simply because they
could is your blood boiling yet it
should be
reasonable people could surmise that
this is a dry run of a disgraceful and
illegal effort by the government to
normalize the tracking of individual
americans categorizing them and using
that information for law enforcement and
even for political organizing purposes
the cdc clearly feels they are above the
law and other constitutional decencies
and was perfectly comfortable initiating
mass surveillance on innocent people
living their lives the question now
becomes what's tracked next what about
parents attending a school board meeting
or how about people visiting a gun store
or how about individual tracking of
people who attend a trump rally
remember the biden administration is
challenging the overturning of the mask
mandate not because it's imperative to
your health in their statement they said
they were doing it to preserve the cdc's
authority
to do whatever they deemed necessary
during an emergency the good news is
it's now clear there must be legislation
to stop this repugnant practice in its
tracks the just the news website
reported senator rand paul a fierce
protector of freedom and privacy says it
is time to ban federal agencies from
being able to track americans behavior
by buying their cell phone location data
from commercial vendors
he said when the government is trying to
snoop on your behavior it's wrong and
there should be a law against it
this is a bill languishing in congress
called the fourth amendment is not for
sale act stopping the federal government
from buying location information without
a warrant
contacting your representatives is
imperative so they know you are aware of
what's happening and that this end run
against the fourth amendment must be
stopped in its tracks
this is tammy bruce fox news contributor
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
i'm guy benson join me weekdays at 3 p.m
eastern as we break down the biggest
stories of the day with some of the
biggest newsmakers and guests listen
live on the fox news app or get the free
podcast at guybensonshow.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes